hello the Nostalgia Critic I remember it
so you don't have to and see how we are
still in the middle of Swartz another
month knock me down
cook it down good I'm gonna have to put
up with that all month on a I've decided
that I want to show you how a
Schwarzenegger movie is made hey studio
executives I have an idea for a movie a
movie our post will a poster of course
go on
I see Arnold Schwarzenegger with
children we're singing that Oh baby
that's old he's pregnant go on and on
the poster he's got like this huge belly
and everything he's just like wow I'm
pregnant
that doesn't happen my name is true man
that doesn't happen and I'm the poster
we'll have that short guy from twins
that everyone will be like hey look it's
that guy from twins I thought it wasn't
twins this must be twins but it's not
twins
it's not twin unless our dough gets
burnt two twins I didn't even think of
that
you got some British chick in it yeah we
got to class it up somehow a British
woman usually works just put it out on
the bottom Carter like we always do
she's not around yet well where's Emma
Thompson greenlighter
Junior
this is another one of those Arnold
movies that sounds more like a satire
than actual film it doesn't even sound
real but it is so sadly it is Arnold
gets pranked and hilarity ensues oh the
high jinks oh the high jinks so get your
at the girls ready because we're gonna
jump right into junior so it starts off
with Arnold in the library I'm sorry I I
got a steal a joke here hold on
Conan the librarian sorry about that
all right back to the show we see that
Arnold comes across a baby in the middle
of the library hello there's a baby
is be enchanting pissing pants music
that's always nice to listen to
ah I miss the explosions now right so it
turns out that Arnold is a brilliant
scientist sorry who's trying to find a
way to get bearing women print the body
mistaking be identifies the embryo no no
sorry Arnold that's really not working
it's goodness a new clothing during
sampling no I know you're trying but you
just can't pull off bodybuilding
scientist and take it seriously unless
your wife was frozen you got some sort
of freeze disease that forces you to
actually that don't work either
don't play scientists I found
conclusively that in every instance the
side effects observed were consistent
with the behavioral and metabolic
changes in subjects with normal
unmedicated pregnancies so in other
words it's not a tumor that's what I
thought Danny DeVito as a doctor trying
to help Arnold in his research and they
think they found a drug that actually
works unfortunately they don't get
permission to move forward by testing it
on women so are no place by his own
rules breaks into the laboratory and
locks the door oh come on that's not the
commando way you would have used a
bulldozer to break into that place why
no reason it's just awesome so the help
of review board played by Frank Langella
lets him know what's going on good news
and bad news I'm afraid
FDA decision wicked bad news they turned
us down I'm afraid so
so what's the good news I'm trying out
for the new Christopher Lee I landed dr.
Diana Reagan and her ovum cryogenics
project and this is where Emma Thompson
comes in she's klutzy it's funny ah
they're all right frozen eggs huh yes I
hope one day to open my own amusement
park of dinosaurs what woman is going to
take an unapproved drug while she's
pregnant who says we need a woman the
experiment wouldn't have to identify the
subject sex I mean to do the tests on a
man why not that's a very valid question
why not oh wait maybe because of these
I guess I was wrong about us I took you
for a scientist I am a scientist yeah
where's your vision where's your
power-hungry need to play God
so DeVito finally convinces him to get
off the plane and get himself pregnant
that's that's no small feat but Savino
still needs an aide to implant into
Arnold and a vagina and a fucking uterus
okay I digress Junior
make sure Junior so the implant Arnold
seed into the Arnold as he wakes up and
finds a very pleasant image hello yes
and hey look she has a baby goodbye
oh my ears I've never seen anything like
it
20 straight hours of Marathon projectile
vomiting geez so I recommend ah well
certainly no more watching of junior
that much is certain
well he does need to finish the review
well then certainly no more watching of
that scene by the way did you turn the
TV off
no I thought you did your turn to clean
it up man
now back to the review so even though
they're not working the lab anymore
aren't Alan DeVito still hanging around
for some reason and watch Emma Thompson
work my nipple is a very sensitive what
like tingling like sore like itchy you
surf huh surf cuz I got that a lot from
paddling out it's something about the
way the wax and the salt water to
irritates them you get what his nipples
are tingling I don't surf it could be
your laundry detergent I used to get
that when I used a non biodegradable
soap um I'm sorry but uh where the jokes
Amin's there anything funny being said
right now away I don't know
cut to the next scene where have you
been I had so much fun I had to walk the
most wonderful massage in a health club
by the great time then they took a nap
right down a table
Frank's in blankets oh these are my
favorites
this isn't funny either okay let's try
not see you should try being a woman
sometime it's a nightmare
your body goes peculiar with your first
period and it doesn't stop until
menopause it's a lifetime of leaking and
swelling and spotting and smears
oh that's just unpleasant come on guys
make us laugh there is a tragic disease
it's a relentless kind of out this
madness
yes striking young men in their prime
turning them into big wheezing uh brutal
homes
strudel hunts strudel hounds yet puns
why'd you punch line we should go
going going always going and when they
gone just like that
it's just conversations really unfunny
conversations seriously this is Arnold
Schwarzenegger pregnant I don't expect
it to be great but I expect to be a
little funny okay all right here's a
semen to vito's ex-wife who happens to
be pregnant but won't say who the father
is
however she wants to veto to be the
doctor all right this is good plenty of
setups for good jokes here so what do
you want
I don't like sneller Angela we've been
over this
Ned sneller is a top top guy he's creepy
Larry I'm not going back to him you're
being ridiculous not okay this is like a
game show in fact it's practically an
adventure the adventure of finding the
jump
hola I'm Dora and we're trying to find a
joke in junior let's see if you can stop
one are you ready oh I'm a little
shocked here well I think you're gonna
have to deal with it
I don't have to deal with it because
we're divorced remember it's not like
I'm asking you to fix my car
nothing yet Angela this is my house now
Larry you may live here this will always
be my house
floral houndstooth then Paisley
that's not the least bit funny where's
the Guardian father haven't been able to
reach him what he disappeared Oh they've
they're touring who is Arrowsmith show
this next time which knowing this films
poor pacing will be very shortly so are
goes and wonders what it would be like
to be a Papa hmm och Bush Walt's America
Governor Schwarzenegger so I guess
Arnold goes through some of the motions
like crying and emotional commercials
and being a little needy but that's the
key word here little everything is
downplaying which is usually a good move
but here just the fact that are those
pregnant and not a woman isn't really
funny it's just boring they're treating
it like a real pregnancy which is boring
watching a person male or female being
pregnant isn't funny it's boring you
mean humor this is boring are not saying
he's fed every once in a while doesn't
cut it it's boring
either give him a gun or throw in some
jokes cuz I'm getting really tired of it
oh ma girl breathing because pregnant
women do that and therefore this is
funny
I suppose anybody ever tell you that you
eat like a pregnant woman I just like
mixing cuisines I'm sorry I am losing my
touch
I mean this is just so boring I'm
nothing to work with and it doesn't seem
possible
it does seem only possible it's Arnold
Schwarzenegger pregnant something has to
be funny about this what are you doing
wrong Ivan Reitman
what are you doing wrong I hate my body
looking prosperous there
the pants are loose around the waist I
can take them in the grove all right all
right it turns out the egg is actually
I'm a Thompson's egg Frank Langella
wants crediting though he'd do anything
whoo so Arnold runs away and he flees to
some sort of retreat for pregnant women
and and it's so incredibly boring isn't
there anything you can throw at us movie
hello hi mr. mrs. head yes yes yes this
is the return to the bullshit I was
waiting for oh wait does he talk like a
woman - we know was a sports woman of
the East German I feel wonderful
Duran some lame one-liners as well my
body my choice the aisle I don't and lo
know Greta don't know how well that will
mind it worked another my body my choice
is bullshit we're back to bullshit thank
you thank you for coming home oh okay so
missus not a man checks herself in and
explains her condition they dispensed
anabolic steroids as freely as here in
America the toilet Gatorade big pushed
it on to steroids also give you an
Adam's apple so something should
question that so just when you think a
pregnant eight-foot Austrian man in a
dress couldn't possibly not be funny
what do they do so much Mahajan there's
nothing they play a pop song yes folks
this is supposed to be taken seriously
I'm I'm just disturbed now I'm disturbed
for everyone involved in this movie I
mean I have no idea what they're trying
to get across
why is this being taken so seriously and
seriously my arnold in a truss talking
like a whooping stars to be taken
seriously you know what fuck just fuck
it i'm gonna go back to sleep no I'm not
okay but what I am gonna do is wrap this
up
Arnold finally goes into labor as does
DeVito's ex-wife
he gives birth through squeezing it out
his penis I have no idea and he becomes
the happiest Poppa mom of Weber lid
DeVito's ex-wife gives birth and he gets
her back because he got her on the brain
and rebound could give it another chance
and they all live happily fucking ever
after
oh thank god he gets with the secret
word for the day is boring I mean it's
bad when I'm actually praying for it to
be insensitive and insulting at least
maybe we can get some form of humor
across I mean okay I guess the actors
are all right and Arnold doesn't come
across actually is that bad in this but
that's part of the problem we want him
to be bad in this of all the movies we
want to be over-the-top and goofy in
this is the one it's almost like the
movie was written for a real pregnant
woman and they're the last man they
decided to throw Arnall in weird casting
change but there it is even though the
ironic thing is director ivan reitman
son would go on to direct a really good
pregnant comedy called Juno I guess he's
trying to make up for the sins of the
father
I mean if I've been right there was
directing Juno how do you think it
turned out he probably put Arnold in
there yeah all Schwarzenegger as a
pregnant th girl he'd probably do it
totally serious ki imagine how that
would look the picture we don't have a
picture showing something I said a joke
for crying out loud
Oh